j'ouvre tout de suite le second débat de
ce sens public avec cette question
comment réguler comment sécuriser
l'espace numérique le Sénat voté une loi
hier qui prévoit des mesures alors si tu
dois assez protéiforme pour lutter
contre le cyber-harcèlement l'accès des
enfants aussi de porno les arnaques par
mail ou par SMS l'article permettant en
revanche de bloquer les incitations à la
violence en cas de Me tu as été remis à
plus tard on vous explique pourquoi avec
Audrey vettaz
au plus fort des violences urbaines des
vidéos comme celle-ci déferles sur les
réseaux sociaux pour être sûr incendiées
affrontement avec la police magasin
vandalisé ou pillés souvent elles sont
postées par les auteurs eux-mêmes qui se
géolocalisent ce qui permet aux jeunes
de savoir où se retrouver sur ce réseau
social par exemple plus il y a de vidéos
postées à un endroit plus le nuage
devient rouge il a été démontré que
certaines plateforme ont contribué à
diffuser toujours plus ces images
répréhensibles qui ont aussi conforté
les émeutiers dans leur action des
plateformes pointées du doigt jusqu'au
sommet de l'État Emmanuel Macron
lui-même envisage une solution drastique
quand les choses s'emballent il faut
peut-être se mettre en situation de les
réguler ou de les couper au Sénat le LR
Patrick chaise lui emboîte le pas avec
un amendement qui s'avérerait en l'état
inconstitutionnel mais qui a surtout
pour but d'appeler à la réflexion
amendement a pour objet de permettre aux
autorités administratives compétentes
d'émettre des la jonction de retrait à
l'encontre des réseaux sociaux afin
qu'ils retirent ou bloque l'accès dans
un délai de deux heures au contenu
incitant de façon manifeste à la
violence des propositions qui font
bondir à gauche je suis très inquiet
aussi par les paroles du président qui
proposent de couper les réseaux sociaux
comme on le fait dans des régimes
autoritaires ou moins démocrate que le
nôtre voilà quelques heures plus tard
l'exécutive précise et semble faire
machine arrière sur la proposition du
président de fonctionnalités que vous
avez par exemple des fonctions de sur
certaines plateformes de géolocalisation
qui permettent à des jeunes de se
retrouver à tel endroit en montrant des
scènes et comment mettre le feu etc et
donc c'est des appels à organisation de
la haine dans l'espace public et là vous
avez autorité pour pouvoir suspendre le
temps de le gouvernement d'y vouloir
opter pour une réflexion autant long
avec la mise en place dès mercredi d'un
groupe de travail transpartisan sur le
sujet
comment sécuriser l'espace numérique
vaste défi on en débat avec Nathalie
Sonac bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
professeur université Panthéon Assas
président du Conseil d'Orientation et de
perfectionnement du centre de liaison de
l'enseignement et des médias
l'information anciennement du CSA
évidemment et auteur de ce livre le
nouveau monde des médias urgences
démocratiques publiés aux éditions Odile
Jacob j'accueille Olivier lascar bonsoir
bienvenue à vous vous êtes rédacteur en
chef du pôle digital de Sciences et
Avenir la recherche et auteur de cette
enquête sur Elon Musk l'homme qui défie
la science libre publié aux éditions
alizio Justine Atlan bonsoir bienvenue
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
vous êtes directrice de l'association et
enfance j'accueille également avec nous
en duplex en visioconférence Patrick
chaise le sénateur LR de l'un bonsoir
vous êtes co-rapporter de ce projet de
loi sur de sécurisation de l'espace
numérique et évidemment laetitia cruppa
est resté à mes côtés je rebondis sur le
sujet sur la question des réseaux
sociaux sus prendre les réseaux sociaux
en période voilà de violence urbaine
Nathalie saunach c'est presque c'est un
débat très ancien entre sécurité et
liberté qui ressort à cette
occasion là c'est vrai qu'on peut dire
que les réseaux sociaux en tout cas
certains
usages ont servi d'amplificateur aux
émeutes est-ce qu'il faut se donner des
moyens législatifs parce que c'est
l'enjeu en ce moment de freiner ces
appels à la violence ce qui est
indispensable effectivement c'est qu'on
parvienne à déterminer un cadre de
régulation qui attrape les mauvaises
actions et tant de limiter au maximum la
circulation des contenus illicites et
dans le même temps laisse toute la
liberté d'expression et de communication
que nous permettent à la fois ces les
sites les réseaux sociaux et depuis
maintenant une vingtaine d'années le web
le web 2 donc on est bien en arbitrage
toujours mais c'est c'est bien le rôle
de l'arcom aussi quand on a succédé au
CSA effectivement une autorité de
régulation indépendante qui est toujours
en train d'arbitrer sur une ligne de
crête entre si j'interviens avant c'est
de la censure et si j'interviens après
et bien il faut une qui soit tout à fait
à l'échelle de de du manquement posé là
effectivement la question de de violence
sur la question de façon plus plus
générale de contenu qui circule de
pédopornographie de cyber-harcèlement ou
tout simplement de la désinformation
quand je dis tout simplement c'est parce
qu'on parle tellement de la
désinformation qui attaque un
directement no fondamentaux note
démocratie et qu'il faut absolument
parvenir à les contenir donc la loi me
semble et un nouveau cadre indispensable
on y reviendra évidemment la loi qui a
été votée ce mercredi soir mais aussi le
règlement le nouveau règlement européen
les nouveaux règlements européens qui
permettent d'aller plus loin Olivier ça
techniquement un état c'est pas très
compliqué un état peut couper le tuyau
en quelque sorte un réseau social à une
plateforme sauf qu'effectivement on
l'entendait un sujet c'est plutôt dans
les dans des états dans des régimes
autocratiques on va dire qu'on pratique
ça effectivement il y a pas Google en
Chine par exemple donc c'est tout à fait
techniquement possible
avec un usage différent on en parlera de
Tik Tok tout à l'heure et
donc mais oui effectivement en termes de
symbole ce serait complètement
c'est vraiment pas compliqué c'est
possible
on le verra pas arriver ça même quand on
voit un Twitter avec musk qui joue les
flibustiers en laissant penser qu'il ne
suivra que les règles qu'il sait donner
lui-même ça se passera pas comme ça
parce que c'est géant du numérique et au
premier chef les géants qui viennent des
États-Unis ils ont trop besoin des
marchés européens du point de vue des
gros sous parce que ça leur ramène
départ de marché considérables donc ils
ne vont pas renoncer à ces marchés parce
que il ne voudrait pas respecter ses
règles au contraire on a plutôt
l'impression que c'est géant des gafams
vont prendre des Américains on parle pas
de Tik Tok qu'on voit s'afficher sur les
écrans derrière vous il est tellement
omniprésent il est encore fait parler de
lui aujourd'hui Tik Tok avec
ces commentaires dessinateurs qui disent
que c'est trop adossé justement vous
êtes en train de manger un thème qu'on
va parler un peu plus tard
donc les Américains oui les Américains
ont trop besoin des marchés européens et
au contraire on a plutôt l'impression
qu'ils vont jouer le jeu de ces règles
donc on peut les citer tout de suite
peut-être le DMA comme le digital market
Act et le DSA comme digital services
actes le premier il est plutôt
économique le second il est plutôt sur
les contenus et ce sont des règles qui
vont être donnés à ces géants pour
respecter d'un côté des questions de
concurrence de l'autre de des fameux
appel à illicite contenu et on peut
considérer qu'effectivement ça change la
donne et d'ailleurs la loi qui a été
votée ce mercredi soir c'est c'est pour
que le le la France se met en conformité
on va dire avec les nouvelles règles
européen Justin je voudrais m'appuyer
sur votre expérience vous vous
discussions avec les gens d'Internet qui
possèdent évidemment ces réseaux sociaux
sur leur
un peu une évidence mais on va le
rappeler c'est important de le rappeler
sur leurs moyens de modération de quoi
enfin voilà je vous vois je vous vois
sourire parce que le mot et le mot est
beaucoup trop fort c'est ça c'est il y a
mais ils sont sous-dimensionnés mais
dans la question c'est qu'on ne sait pas
en fait je serais bien incapable de vous
le dire puisque en fait le problème
qu'on a c'est que il manque de
transparence réelle
sur effectivement les moyens qui sont
mis en place pour la modération parce
que là dans le cas des émeutes on
pourrait dire que des moyens de
modération aurait pu fonctionner pour
dire attention il y a des appels à la
violence
il y a 20 ans c'est pas la même chose
qu'aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
quand on est moyen de modération ça
suppose deux facteurs il y a tout ce
qu'on appelle intelligence artificielle
aujourd'hui c'est à dire toute la
modération par du machine learning etc
qui aujourd'hui en 2023 effectivement
des moyens extraordinaires et je pense
qu'en plus l'accès que tout le monde a
eu aujourd'hui à tchadjibiti etc fait
comprendre aux gens la puissance d'une
intelligence artificielle et donc à quel
point on peut en faire un peu ce qu'on
veut et que donc effectivement au
service de la modération certaine qui
pourrait faire plus et puis il y a les
moyens humains parce que la modération
ce qui pose problème en général c'est ce
qu'on appelle la zone grise c'est à dire
c'est ces fameux contenus qui sont ni
blanc ni noir mais qui ne demandent du
coup une contextualisation une
appréciation et là c'est de l'humain qui
doit intervenir et ça en fait on a à
côté de déclarations des plateformes qui
est affiche un certain nombre de
milliers voire compte que des milliers
par rapport à des centaines de million
d'utilisateurs dans le monde c'est pas
beaucoup mais qui affiche des milliers
voilà de modérateurs on sait pas où ils
sont on sait pas combien ils sont et
encore une fois on n'a pas accès
directement c'est eux qui disent mais on
ne sait pas vraiment combien il y en a
ou s'il y a pas de normes là-dessus
parce que que la question est-ce que
l'on n'aurait pas dormi un pourcentage
du chiffre d'affaires en fonction du
nombre d'utilisateurs qui assurent une
plateforme des choses comme ça donc
voilà c'est une zone fou faut pas dire
qu'il y a rien c'est pas vrai sinon ça
serait bien
alors des choses mais on sait pas
combien alors je reviens et on va
rentrer en détail sur cette loi qui a
été votée à l'unanimité c'est important
de le signaler par le Sénat ce mercredi
soir l'autre sécurisation de l'espace
numérique je le disais en amorce elle
est protéiforme elle adapte en français
au nouveau règlement européen on va
écouter le ministre Jean-Noël Barrault
qui nous disent il s'agit d'abord de
protéger nos enfants nos petits-enfants
nos enfants ne pouvaient plus attendre
car nos enfants sont les principales
victimes des travers de la société
numérique vous l'avez rappelé madame la
rapporteur surexposition aux écrans
addiction aux réseaux sociaux
cyber-harcèlement exposition précoce à
des contenus inappropriés autant
d'atteinte brutale à leur innocence
autant de violences psychologiques
faites à une génération qui risque bien
d'être
sacrifiés si rien n'est fait alors quand
le ministre parle d'exposition précoce à
des contenus inappropriés il faut dire
les choses on parle de pornographie la
moitié des garçons de 12-13 ans
consultent des sites pornographiques
chaque mois
la moitié c'est un chiffre qu'il faut
peut-être retenir de cette émission
c'est ça la moitié des garçons de 12-13
ans consulte décide pornographiques
chaque mois Justine Atlan est-ce que cet
accès inintervient de plus en plus tôt
et puis surtout c'est le plus important
qu'elles en sont les conséquences est-ce
qu'on peut le
préciser ça je pense qu'on peut
l'imaginer un peu effectivement commencé
à le voir la conséquence immédiate d'un
enfant ou d'un jeune préadolescent qui
est confronté à des images
pornographiques telles qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui donc sur ce qu'on appelle
les tubes c'est à dire c'est ces
plateformes on a accès à des contenus
très courts qui ont l'air plus ou moins
amateur sans forcément l'être d'abord
c'est une infraction psychique très
violente c'est un traumatisme psychique
parce qu'en fait le cerveau d'un enfant
n'est pas prêt à voir et à recevoir ces
images puisqu'il ne sait pas dans quelle
case les mettre dans son cerveau qui
n'est pas préparé à ça donc on le sait
les enfants ont l'impression qu'ils
achètent à une scène violente pour eux
la sexualité c'est quelque chose de
violent et sur ces contenus là ça peut
l'être réellement donc voilà donc en
fait c'est extrêmement traumatisant pour
eux donc ça ça génère des problèmes de
sommeil des cauchemars des comportements
parfois sexuels on se rend compte qu'un
enfant vieux des images pornographiques
parce qu'un petit garçon une petite
fille va être agressif sexuellement avec
ses camarades à l'école et que c'est
comme ça qu'on se rencontre qu'il a vu
des donc il faut que ça aille s'évacue
et ça peut s'évacuer avec des
comportements voilà qui peuvent être
violents pour les autres et puis par
ailleurs évidemment il y a la
construction de la vie sexuelle ensuite
des ados qui va se construire avec ce
modèle là parce que c'est ça que ça leur
sert et là ça cause des problèmes de
consentement ensuite dans les rapports
voilà de pas mal de choses donc c'est
immédiat et puis au moyen à long terme
alors je me tourne une première fois
vers Patrick chaise qui est évidemment
avec nous en duplex que va permettre la
loi en matière de lutte contre la
pornographie monsieur le sénateur
alors la loi elle va permettre justement
de réguler et de sécuriser en faisant en
sorte que donc les plateformes et un
devoir de suspension de contenu qui
apparaissent donc illicite mais aussi de
donner la responsabilité à ces
plateformes de pouvoir mettre en place
des outils qui interdiront l'accès aux
personnes mineures assez contenu avec
donc tout un
processus avec tout un tas de d'outils
qu'il sera donc obligatoire de mettre en
place et de pouvoir réguler est-ce que
ça passe par exemple je reste avec vous
par des parce que là aussi la
technologie permet des systèmes de
reconnaissance par exemple de
reconnaissance faciale permettent de
dire
mais c'est l'utilisation effectivement
des images pour pouvoir détecter et
définir l'âge
la biométrie me
dit Justine Atlan merci de m'aider il
faut être il faut être précis on essaye
une case
et donc personne ne peut savoir si on a
plus ou moins et alors je viens de
tourner vers vous notre histoire pour
savoir parce que vous étiez au CSA qui
est devenu l'art comme aujourd'hui donc
les les pouvoirs de l'arcom sont on va
dire un peu élargi sauf qu'on avait le
sentiment que le CSA comme la recommande
pouvait rien faire face au site porno
pourquoi parce qu'ils sont pas basés en
France le plus souvent et expliquez-nous
pourquoi il y avait ce sentiment
d'impuissance je pense que déjà parce
que d'un point de vue technique il faut
il faut cette mise en place ensuite la
régulation européenne elle aussi doit
s'entendre et on voit bien qu'on n'a pas
le même arsenal juridique à la fois en
Chine et on en est content mais en même
temps aux États-Unis ou les la question
du rgpd de la vie privée n'est pas la
même ensuite effectivement général de
protection des données ensuite
effectivement il suffit c'était du
déclaratif maintenant on est en train de
Souter on voit bien qu'au filtre alors
[Musique]
c'est toujours facile de dire on
intergit versait parce que ça va très
vite ce dont ce qui donne plus surtout
cette impression c'est que depuis 20 ans
le numérique a envahi notre espace
complètement de vie et que chaque année
qui qui se suit amplifie finalement à la
fois la capacité de ces nouveaux acteurs
l'auto de pénétration et nous notre
acceptation dans notre espace de vie
commune donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle finalement il y a quand même
deux grandes dimensions dans laquelle il
faut il faut jouer il faut à la fois
jouer sur le cadre européen qui est
indispensable on a parlé comme on dit du
Règlement sur les services numériques en
bon français j'essayais de regarder le
terme pour pas tromper parce que je me
fais à chaque fois taper sur les doigts
donc ce fameux DSA qui conduit qui est
quand même un pas très important c'est à
dire que l'Europe est en train de se
doter d'un règlement qui sera appliqué à
l'identique dans l'ensemble des pays
européens ce qui constitue quand même
une arme importante puisqu'on s'entend
tous et les plateformes ne vont pas
pouvoir jouer au petit malin en disant
si je ne suis pas installé en France
finalement j'ai qu'à mettre en Irlande
ça c'est quand même cette question de
géographie et fondamentale ensuite il y
a la question de la responsabilité elles
ne vont plus pouvoir se cacher derrière
leur modèle d'affaires finalement moi je
ne peux pas parce que mon algorithme
j'ai besoin de le projet ça c'est le
plus possible donc il y a cette
responsabilité là ensuite il y a un
troisième un troisième point qui est
véritablement les moyens donc le
règlement les oblige à ce qu'il y ait ce
qu'ils mettent en place à la fois des
moyens vous le disiez justement de
modération humaine et en même temps de
moyens techniques c'est là que peut-être
il va falloir d'ores et déjà et qu'on
loupe pas le coche que la Commission
européenne une fois qu'elle a fait
passer ce doute bien elle-même de moyens
humains pour suivre la bonne application
et ça va être là qu'il va falloir
regarder ça de très près on y reviendra
sur ce digital service hack mais je
voudrais sur l'aspect technologique
quelque chose de très intéressant de ce
que nous disait Nathalie Sonac parce que
on a souvent je sais pas si vous dirait
souvent ou tout le temps mais le
sentiment que les politiques ont un coût
de retard quoi par rapport à l'évolution
de l'offre sur sur les plateformes sur
les médias sociaux il y a clairement un
problème de tempo depuis ces fameuses 20
dernières années le temps de la
technologie n'a vraiment pas été celle
du législateur par ailleurs on est dans
des domaines de l'innovation
technologique qui sont connotés très
positivement on a un président de la
République qui parle de start-up nation
de disruption donc on a été un petit peu
candide par rapport à ces économies qui
qui se sont développés il y a une
vingtaine d'années l'économie de la data
c'est celle de Facebook de Google et
tout ça on connaissait pas avant donc
les mesures anticoncurentielles qui
pouvaient donner le la dans l'économie
elles ont eu du mal à s'adapter à ces
nouveaux marchés caduques face à ces
nouveaux marchés quasiment complètement
n'a jamais rattrapé le retard c'est à
dire qu'on a été largué tout de suite et
on a l'impression que les politiques
alors on n'est jamais réussi à reprendre
l'impression que avec ce fameux DSA DMA
il y a quand même une révolution
copernicienne qui est en train de se
passer les les experts de de ces
questions là nous le disent quand on
quand on travaille avec eux quand on
fait des papiers pour se lancer à venir
par exemple il se passe quelque chose et
notamment par rapport à la question de
la modération que vous disiez tout à
l'heure il va y avoir cette obligation
d'ouvrir les serveurs que Twitter
Facebook et compagnie vont devoir ouvrir
leurs serveurs à des auditeurs
extérieurs et c'est pour ça que le point
que vous disiez aussi extrêmement
important il va falloir maintenant et
c'est ce nouveau coach qu'il faudrait
pas louper il faudrait que maintenant on
ait la ressource en France et en Europe
des ingénieurs des experts qui vont
pouvoir mettre le nez dans ses serveurs
et il comprend quelque chose ça c'est
vraiment un point qui me semble vraiment
fondamental c'est à dire que une fois
qu'on a défini cette ce cadre normatif
il faut absolument nous-même donc la
Commission européenne en l'occurrence se
dotent de moyens humains pour pouvoir
suivre cette ce nouveau cadre et je me
trouve quand même relativement sévère
parce que bien sûr que de toute manière
le gendarme pour toujours après le
le voleur mais le rgpd a été un élément
le rgpd était quand même une avancée et
puis les attentats de creachers on a
quand même à ce moment là l'ensemble des
plateformes se sont mobilisées et c'est
ça où on va continuer d'en parler c'est
de de ces progrès Laetitia on va on va
voir que cette ces enjeux de régulation
de maîtrise des réseaux sociaux c'est
pas une obsession française toutes les
démocraties s'y mettent toutes les
démocraties en Europe vous avez raison
mais les États-Unis aussi en Europe le
digital servte mais alors je suis pas
aussi enthousiaste que vous parce que
j'ai l'impression que certes là on a
posé les bases pour réguler mais que
tous les pays ne comprennent pas ces
bases de la même façon et ne vont
peut-être pas les expliquer de la même
façon c'est l'enjeu en tout cas à très
court terme pour cette régulation au
niveau européen et c'est vrai que pour
le moment
c'est tout de même un règlement on est
d'accord
c'est un règlement donc et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que le Sénat a voté
cette loi pour je le répète faire
rentrer ce règlement européen dans le
droit français alors ce qu'on sait c'est
que il y a des injonctions judiciaires
qui fonctionnent et que les plateformes
appliquent déjà écoutez oui quand il y a
un tribunal qui ordonne de retirer telle
ou tel contenu en règle générale Thomas
s'est respecté le casse-tête et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure madame c'est
pour toutes les démocraties c'est la
modération c'est avant c'est comment
contrôler les contenus a priori et c'est
là où on rentre en compte l'intelligence
artificielle il y a déjà des dispositifs
qui existent par exemple sur Instagram
vous ne pouvez pas poster de photos ou
de vidéos de personnes dénudées donc il
y a bien une forme de collaboration déjà
une forme de modération qui existe
bah oui parce que ces modèles
économiques sur lesquels repose ses
réseaux sociaux c'est un modèle qui est
basé sur l'attention et l'audience
Thomas le but c'est d'avoir le plus de
monde possible le plus longtemps parce
qu'on sait bien que si un réseau est
trop restrictif les utilisateurs vont
aller ailleurs et discuter ailleurs donc
finalement quand on réfléchit un peu au
problème on se dit et si c'était les
utilisateurs le vrai nœud du problème
parce que ce sont les utilisateurs qui
créent les contenus et que l'État tente
ensuite de réguler et regardez ce qui se
passe en France quand l'État veut
réguler on sort tout de suite la
pancarte atteinte à nos libertés
publiques censure donc c'est l'opinion
publique qui serait un frein voir le
premier frein exactement et on va
prendre
l'ex aux États-Unis 50 millions
d'utilisateurs quand même le Sénat
américain a reçu et de auditionner son
son directeur général en mars dernier
tout a été filmé un diffusé comme cette
séquence je vous propose cette séquence
regardez bien un député interroge donc
le directeur de Tik Tok à propos du
suicide d'un très jeune utilisateur qui
avait 16 ans regardez
[Musique]
on aurait pu croire que cette vidéo
était vraiment dévastatrice pour l'image
de Tik Tok et de son PDG bien non les
utilisateurs de Tik Tok se sont moqués
et c'est vraiment plusieurs millions de
messages de tout le Sénat américain qui
leur semblait totalement déconnecté et
hors sol donc c'est un très bon exemple
pour comprendre que si l'opinion
publique les utilisateurs de ces réseaux
n'adhèrent pas du tout à la volonté
politique de réguler
la tâche s'annonce ardue voire quasiment
impossible votre avis là-dessus Justin
le finalement notre rôle à tous parce
que pourquoi ces médias sociaux ces
réseaux sociaux ont pris une telle
ampleur c'est pas parce que voilà on
s'est créé un nouveau besoin de
nouvelles habitudes à une sorte de
confort de vie parfois et puis tellement
de choses merveilleuses à faire avec des
réseaux sociaux il faut enfin voilà on
s'est un accès à la culture c'est on
peut parler avec nos amis partager quand
on est à l'autre bout du monde avec
quelqu'un de sa famille enfin voilà on
va pas être dans un dans un ressenti
totalement binaire et et négatif quel
est notre part de responsabilité dans
dans ce succès gigantesque et dans
finalement le manque de moyens que ces
réseaux sociaux mettent dans la
modération non alors on ne jugerait pas
jusqu'à dire qu'on est responsable du
manque de moyens qui mettent dans la
modération la peut-être qu'on les quitte
pas ces réseaux sociaux malgré le manque
de modération
mais ils ont créé un modèle extrêmement
séduisant on nourrit la bête tout à fait
ça je pense que ça révèle on en parle
avec ça ça révèle certainement des
failles dans qui préexistaient aux
réseaux sociaux aura été certaine nous a
montré qu'il y a des endroits où on
était très fragiles effectivement ça
montre que l'éducation à la citoyenneté
l'éducation toutes les informations
c'est des à la laïcité peut-être enfin
il y a des sujets ça les a fait émerger
de façon très forte et on se rend compte
que là on n'était pas outillés
effectivement individuellement et
collectivement et peut-être dans
certains pays plus ou moins que d'autres
voilà ça c'est une évidence pour autant
c'est un peu le discours quand même des
plateformes régulièrement de dire que
c'est de la faute des autres donc j'aime
pas trop basculer trop là dedans c'est
la faute des utilisateurs qui savent pas
bien fonctionné c'est la faute des
parents qui est du mal leurs enfants
voilà donc à un moment oui mais pas que
non plus c'est quand même qu'on
fabriquez ces outils là de façon assez
clairvoyante mais il savait pas
forcément anticiper toutes les dérives
et qu'en tout cas celui qui maîtrise
effectivement est particulièrement bien
tout ce qu'ils font parce qu'on n'a pas
accès aux algorithmes on n'a pas accès à
l'intérieur de comment il fabrique les
choses et ça ça reste quand même un vrai
sujet pourquoi il cache
conduit le PDG évidemment et alors
j'aurais juste vous dire que je pense
parce que l'autre jour des journalistes
me poser la question de ce entre
guillemets momentum autour de la
protection de l'enfant sur Internet
c'est vrai qu'il y a il y a beaucoup de
textes là qui sont sortis là-dessus ça
va pas et j'entendais j'en ai dans les
barreaux qui a introduit ce texte sur la
sécurité à travers ce sujet là donc je
pense aussi qu'aujourd'hui le ministre
selon les ministres que que je vais pas
évidemment je peux m'en réjouir mais
néanmoins que cette protection de
l'enfance sert aux politiques je pense
effectivement parce que c'est assez
fédérateur comme comme sujet à pouvoir
légitimer des interventions d'une
régulation assez forte et que peut-être
que pour justement contrer cette
adhésion cette popularité des réseaux
sociaux ils ont besoin d'avoir un sujet
suffisamment fort en face il fasse
vraiment adhésion et je pense la
protection en étain effectivement qui le
fait mais il faut pas non plus alors je
devrais pas dire ça sera du côté du
politique évidemment voilà donc je pense
que là-dessus il y a quelque chose sans
doute qui se joue aussi alors sur
l'action des États et des démocraties
qui on va écouter puisqu'on parlait on
en a déjà parlé assez longuement mais de
ces deux règlements votés au niveau
européen on va écouter celui qui est à
la manœuvre le commissaire européen au
Marché intérieur c'est un français
ancien ministre Thierry Breton écouter
du reste c'était un peu le Far West
c'était à leur main nous avons repris le
pouvoir parce que nous sommes des
autorités politiques et nous leur avons
dit vous êtes évidemment le bienvenu
vous êtes le bienvenu dans cet espace
que représente les bandes marché
intérieur et maintenant le marché
intérieur numérique mais seulement voilà
nos règles et donc je rappelle ce qu'il
y a dans ce digital services actes qui
va rentrer en vigueur le 25 août ça
concerne les plus grosses plateformes et
devant se soumettre à toute une série de
contrôles on va dire Microsoft Twitter
Tik Tok Amazon Apple Google etc etc si
elle n'obtente perd pas la commission
menace de les retirer du marché européen
et des amendes sont également prévues
jusqu'à
6% de leur chiffre d'affaires donc 19
plateformes qui dépassent les 45
millions d'utilisateurs Olivier lascar
vous dites c'est vraiment c'est on peut
dire que c'est une nouvelle étape c'est
c'est un vrai coup de force de l'Europe
oui il faut pas toujours se recouvert de
se recouvrir de cendres
il se passe quelque chose d'intéressant
avec ses limites
par exemple on peut se demander pourquoi
avoir fait deux entités différentes des
amas DSA l'un sur l'économie l'autre sur
les contenus alors que comme vous le
disiez les contenus impliquent
directement le l'usage et l'enfermement
qu'on a dans un réseau social et donc
l'économie du modèle les deux sont
intimement liés donc ça c'est différence
elle est un peu à discutable
on a dit que grâce à ces règles
européennes on va avoir accès aux
données des de ces de ces géants des
gafam mais les algorithme comme vous le
disiez aussi reste une boîte noire
Coca-Cola va pas donner la recette de
son soda Twitter Facebook et asta vont
pas dire comment ils font en sorte que
les gens restent encapsuler chez eux et
ça aussi ces problématiques parce que
ces algorithmes qui sont partout
façonnent nos existences dans la presse
par exemple on est producteur de presse
on est complètement assujetti à la façon
dont des outils comme Google actu ou
Apple news vont référencer nos contenus
sur des considérations sur lesquelles on
n'a aucunement la main donc c'est quand
même un problème géant et qui va
continuer un mot pas trichesse là-dessus
parce que finalement la loi qui a été
votée ce mercredi soir je le disais elle
elle vient
appliquer les règlements européens
est-ce que vous avez eu le sentiment ou
la volonté d'aller plus loin où vous
êtes dit ça y est on a on a là un outil
pour vraiment faire faire avancer
la sécurisation on va dire l'espace
numérique
non en fait ce texte il a effectivement
deux volets il a donc le volet qui est
l'intégration dans notre droit français
des règles européennes donc ça j'allais
dire l'espace de négociation était
relativement réduit on a pris ce qui
existait ce qui a été décidé et on l'a
transformé dans les textes mais il y a
eu effectivement plus que cela dans ce
texte notamment sur donc le filtre
entièrement qui est un filtre qui est
donc directement qui intéresse
directement nos concitoyens puisque donc
on a donc construit un outil qui
permettra de faire en sorte que dès lors
qu'on va
identifier un site frauduleux on puisse
l'identifier alerter l'internaute et au
bout de 7 jours le bloquer donc ça c'est
un outil nouveau qui est pas donc
issu du règlement européen deuxième
alors deuxième exemple je vous
interrompre parce que sur cet exemple là
et je vous redonnerai la parole juste
après on a justement avec nous en duplex
Jérôme 16 qui est consultant en
protection des entreprises et fondateurs
de la société op for intelligence
bonsoir à vous merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce message
d'avertissement ce filtre en quelque
sorte vous vous pensez que ce sera un
outil efficace
ce sera un outil parmi d'autres en fait
effectivement il faut le rappeler
l'objectif est de rendre accessible au
maximum de citoyens une protection
contre ces tentatives d'arnaques qui
commencent systématiquement par un lien
piégé qui va vous amener sur un site web
qui va tenter de voler dérober des
informations directeur personnel ou
encore des moyens de paiement donc on
les a tous vu ce sont c'est une amende
un pays c'est
un colis qui est bloqué à la poste etc
etc donc ça n'a rien de nouveau ça
existe certaines navigateur le fond déjà
depuis longtemps il existe des dizaines
de listes qui recense ce type de site
mais c'est un peu éparpillé c'est un
ordre dispersé et là la volonté est
plutôt de d'amener au maximum de
citoyens et en particulier ceux qui sont
le plus loin du numérique ceux qui ne
vont peut-être pas utiliser un
navigateur qui va avoir intégré cette
technologie là ce qui ne vont peut-être
pas installer déployer des outils de
protection qui vont être capable de
vérifier leur navigation et les mettre
en alerte c'est de massifier finalement
cette protection et ça c'est
terriblement important parce que ce type
d'arnaque est souvent à l'origine
notamment d'une usurpation d'identité
une usurpation d'identité c'est ça peut
aller jusqu'à 10 ans de bataille avec
avec des banques avec des assurances
avec des des avec des administrations en
tout genre c'est des crédits qui sont
pris sous le sous sont à son nom donc ça
va dans le bon sens ça n'a rien de
nouveau simplement ça massifie et ça
amène un maximum de citoyens une
protection qui est alors elle n'est pas
parfaite c'est loin d'être une panace et
puisqu'on sait très bien que ces sites
Ness et meurt en quelques heures donc là
l'objectif c'est que au bout de quatre
heures on ne soit capable de me protéger
l'ensemble de la population 4 heures
après une détection donc c'est très bien
les criminels vont probablement
s'adapter mais encore une fois il faut
pas avoir une raison non binaire en
disant bon ben ça ne fonctionne pas à
100% donc on ne le fait pas l'idée
encore une fois et de protéger un
maximum de citoyens qui aujourd'hui ne
bénéficie pas de ces de ces protection
j'ai on sait je reste avec vous quels
sont les les arnaques les plus répandus
aujourd'hui on va pas parler des
entreprises on va pas parler des
hôpitaux etc vraiment pour les pour les
particuliers pour les citoyens que nous
sommes
alors ce qui fait vraiment le plus de
dégâts aujourd'hui c'est c'est le vol
d'identité donc on va l'identité qui ne
se fait pas forcément que en ligne très
souvent on va on va créer un dossier de
location d'appartements et puis ce
dossier là va chuter il va être récupéré
vendu sur le Dark web et ses
informations là vont permettre de créer
un double de la victime et prendre en
son nom des crédit souscrire à tout un
tas d'offres et de choses qu'elle
devrait elle-même rembourser donc ça ça
fait vraiment des ravages c'est entre le
numérique et le monde physique
une autre arnaque très souvent qui fait
qui fait beaucoup de ravages aussi c'est
l'appel du faux conseiller bancaire là
aussi on n'est pas on ne démarre pas
dans du numérique simplement les données
ont été dérobées dans du numérique
potentiellement sur un site frauduleux
comme ce que cette nouvelle initiative
de filtre anti arnaque à vocation à
essayer de limiter et une fois que ces
données là ont été collectées elles sont
vendues sur des forums des forums sur
Dark web sur des groupes télégram par
exemple et là il y a toute une
organisation qui se met en place avec
des gens dont le métier est appelé les
personnes
ils sont très doués c'est ce qu'on
appelle du Social Engineering donc il y
a des scripts qui se vendent d'ailleurs
entre eux pour se faire passer pour un
conseiller de la banque par exemple
prétexter un problème de sécurité
gagner la confiance de la victime par
exemple en lui disant eh bien écoutez on
va vérifier votre numéro de sécurité
sociale pour être sûr que ce soit bien
vous votre numéro c'est bien le 1/72
soit aussi cela beaucoup de gens ne
savent pas que à partir simplement d'un
prénom et d'une date de naissance on est
capable de trouver les trois premiers
chiffres de numéro de sécurité sociale
et donc ces personnes là vont tomber
dans le panneau bon fournir leurs moyens
de paiement par exemple bon aller
jusqu'à fournir le code SMS qui est
envoyé par la banque réaliser toutes les
manœuvres de vérification et vont se
faire dépouiller en fait et là il y a
toute une série de paiements ensuite sur
la carte qui va qui va opérer donc ça ce
sont vraiment les deux arnaques qui
touchent le plus nos concitoyens et très
souvent malheureusement des gens comme
je disais qui sont éloignés du numérique
et qui ne se renseignent pas
suffisamment sur le sur le type
d'escroquerie qui peuvent exister un bon
conseil pour essayer de se prémunir
toujours appelé sa banque ne jamais
penser que parce qu'on nous appelle
c'est la vérité donc toujours prendre le
temps de réfléchir et dire très bien je
raccroche j'appelle ma banque et je
reviens vers vous et ben voilà
généralement s'arrêtent là à ce
moment-là merci beaucoup pour pour ce
témoignage et pour ces conseils je
reviens vers vous Patrick chaise puisque
vous me disiez il y a une première
amélioration par rapport au texte
européen il y en avait une deuxième je
vous écoute
le marché de l'informatique en nuage
donc c'est une avance de phase sur ce
qui est en train de se négocier au
niveau européen européen au niveau du
Data Act donc l'idée c'est de faire en
sorte que les startups qui aujourd'hui
sont hameçonnés par les grandes
plateformes américaines en leur
proposant des avoir donc du sonnant et
du trébuchant
accrochent ces entreprises et ensuite
les renferme jusqu'au moment où elles
veulent sortir et au monde sortie on
leur réclame des sommes astronomiques
qui les mettent en grande difficulté
donc là on a donc le texte fait en sorte
que ces frais de transfert soient
interdits qu'il y ait des possibilités
de frais de migration des prestations
mais pas de frais de transfert pour donc
libérer les entreprises de cette de ce
risque qui est important puis un
troisième que je souhaiterais aussi
évoqué avec vous c'est la définition des
d'une nouvelle catégorie de jeux c'est
le jeu numérique monétisable qui est une
catégorie qui était dans un vide
juridique jusqu'à aujourd'hui donc on a
pour faire simple les jeux vidéos qui
fonctionnent en boucle fermée on a les
jeux d'argent et il y a une nouvelle
catégorie de jeu qui sont des jeux
numériques monétisable c'est à dire
qu'on gagne des objets numériques qui
sont des objets donc uniques
qu'on peut ensuite revendre
soit par échange avec d'autres joueurs
soit directement en se faisant payer
donc cette catégorie de jeu échappait au
jeu d'argent échappe également au jeu
donc vidéo et donc
dans ce texte on a au Sénat défini la
définition définit la définition c'est
pas très beau mais la définition de ces
jeux numériques monétisable et dans la
navette parlementaire on va donc
encadrer donc
merci beaucoup il nous reste une petite
dizaine de minutes dans ce débat et je
voudrais qu'on ouvre un chapitre on a
déjà évoqué plusieurs fois le réseau
social Tik Tok mais on va y consacrer un
chapitre parce que il se trouve que dans
l'actualité il y a aussi une commission
d'enquête du Sénat qui vient de rendre
un rapport qui était qui est très sévère
sur TikTok Tam traduis vous pouvez nous
rejoindre on va bonsoir table commencer
par rappeler quand en quelques mots ce
qu'est Tik Tok et oui ce réseau est
plébiscité par les jeunes Français les
jeunes tout court il est sur le podium
des réseaux préférés de la génération Z
c'est à dire les 16 25 ans 2023 après
Instagram et snapchat il est surtout en
très forte augmentation depuis ces
dernières années en plus 11 % par
rapport à 2022 + 53 par pour cent par
rapport à 2020 et c'est donc dans ce
contexte que le sénateur Claude Malhuret
habituel vilipendeur des réseaux sociaux
a choisi de se pencher sur la tactique
Tik Tok son rapport est intitulé opacité
addiction et ombre chinoise il dénonce
tout d'abord la main mise de la Chine et
du Parti communiste chinois sur ce
réseau social ce qui est d'autant plus
grave que cette plateforme expose les
jeunes à de très nombreux dangers et en
quoi Tik Tok est-il plus que d'autres
grands réseaux dangereux déjà parce que
c'est le réseau le plus addictif c'est
utilisateurs restent en moyenne une
heure 47 par jour sur cette plateforme
ce qui pose donc de façon aiguë tous les
problèmes que l'on constate en matière
de surexposition aux écrans manque de
sommeil anxiété dépression manque de
concentration etc mais ça ne s'arrête
pas là le rapport explique aussi que
plus vous êtes vulnérable plus
l'algorithme de TikTok va comprendre vos
points faibles et pousser vers vous des
contenus particulièrement dangereux
c'est ce que montre une étude du Center
for contring digital le centre canalise
la haine en ligne qui a créé plusieurs
comptes avec un profil type un enfant de
13 ans intéressé par deux sujets en
particulier l'image de soi et la santé
mentale et on constate alors que les
contenus poussés par le réseau social
portent très rapidement très rapidement
ça veut dire deux minutes 30 ça porte
très rapidement sur le suicide et les
troubles alimentaires puis alors il faut
parler aussi des de ces nouveaux défis
dangereux les challenges TikTok oui le
Momo challenge qui pousse à des actions
violentes le Labello challenge qui
incite à la scarification le blackout
challenge qui consiste à retenir sa
respiration jusqu'à l'évanouissement en
gros le jeu du foulard mais sur Tik Tok
un jeu qui a eu des conséquences
dramatiques écoutées Claude Malhuret
les défis dangereux l'Italie a du
Séville renforçant la suspension je dis
bien la suspension de tout accès à
TikTok pour les âges non prouvés à la
suite de la mort d'une fillette due au
jeu du foulard à une sorte de jeu du
foulard
les seuls remèdes que propose TikTok à
cet effet addictive c'est le message à
60 minutes puis à 100 minutes
d'utilisation vous savez sans doute
qu'en Chine
l'application se ferme automatiquement
au bout de 40 minutes
et comme quoi les régimes autoritaires
ont du bon a d'ailleurs rajouté que le
malurel mais bien sûr l'actualité de ces
derniers jours c'est invité également
des conclusions de cette des travaux du
Sénat oui dans quelle mesure les
plateformes sont-elles responsables des
contenus qui circulent pour les
sénateurs la réponse est très claire
écoutez le président de cette commission
d'enquête le socialiste Michael Valais
il y a une différence fondamentale entre
le fait de relater un fait de montrer
qu'à un endroit il y a des faits de
violence qui a un endroit il y a des
mouvements de foule qui a un endroit ça
brûle parce que c'est une information et
puis que il n'appartient pas à grand
monde de décider qu'on invisibilise des
faits qui sont réels dans la société qui
doivent être expliqués et montrer et le
fait d'expliquer que à tel endroit à
telle heure juste après le Zara on va
aller se faire le Adidas et que
rendez-vous dans telle condition ça ce
n'est pas la même chose quand on incite
à la commission d'actes violents
transparente aux émeutes des derniers
jours du coup les sénateurs exigent des
plateformes modération a priori en cas
de graves trouble à l'ordre public et
d'utilisation des plateformes pour
organiser ces troubles ils veulent aussi
que l'autorité administrative dans le
contexte des meute puisse ordonner le
retrait le blocage des contenus ce qui
existe déjà en matière de
pédopornographie ou de terrorisme notez
que la commission d'enquête a fait 21
recommandations et la dernière lasbot
note list doit être bien soulignée les
slenders demandent purement et
simplement la suspension du réseau en
France et dans l'Union européenne si
TikTok ne répond pas aux questions
posées par la commission d'enquête et
n'obéit pas aux injonctions du Sénat
merci beaucoup Tam traduit je voudrais
qu'on se concentre nous reste quelques
minutes c'est passé trop vite ce débat
Justine Atlan sur le les dangers pour
les plus jeunes est-ce que pour vous le
réseau social TikTok aujourd'hui alors
c'est toujours compliqué de répondre à
une question à parler donc elle est un
peu simpliste mais c'est le plus
dangereux
c'est difficile de dire moi ce que je
trouve c'est que Tik Tok nous montre un
espèce de de résultat optimum de ce que
les autres en créa avant c'est-à-dire
qu'en fait pour moi Tik Tok n'a rien
inventé il fait juste beaucoup mieux que
les autres ce qu'ils ont déjà créés
donc c'est peut-être alertant soit mais
il faut être la blé Tic-Toc pour ce
qu'il fait mais quelque part fallait que
parce qu'il fait mieux que les autres ce
que les autres ont inventé donc c'est
quand même le système à nouveau des
réseaux sociaux qu'il faut et regarder
il faut pas s'en arrêter à TikTok sinon
je pense qu'on passe à côté du vrai
sujet la question de la responsabilité
au début voilà effectivement et ils sont
quand même responsables des conséquences
d'un outil qu'ils ont créé qui maîtrise
quand même extrêmement bien personne
aujourd'hui dans le monde ne connaît
aussi bien je pense les leviers de
l'être humain parce qu'il ne joue que
là-dessus pas sur nous machines ils
jouent sur notre richesse leur richesse
on en parlait ce sont nos données c'est
ce qu'on leur dit surtout comment
fonctionne c'est surtout comme un animal
humain bien sûr réagit et on est
complètement on a l'impression qu'on se
n'utilise plus quand même et où les
jeunes aujourd'hui sont intéressants
pour ça parce que ils arrivent à mettre
en place et c'est vrai que c'est un
petit toc qui les pousse à faire ça des
moments où ils arrêtent TikTok ils se
font des pauses Tik Tok parce qu'ils ont
conscience du fait parce que TikTok
effectivement les cape beaucoup qui sont
trop captés et ça c'est intéressant
parce que c'est un des premiers réseaux
sociaux sur lequel les jeunes eux-mêmes
alors pas les 12 ans mais les lycéens
etc commencent à avoir ce sensation là
donc peut-être qu'effectivement ils sont
un peu trop loin ce qui serait assez
intéressant parce que c'est chez eux qui
est la clé c'est eux qui sont les futurs
clients donc c'est eux qui vont pouvoir
avoir vraiment de l'impact sur sur le
modèle qu'on a pas encore employé ce mot
et il est important le mot éducation
bien sûr je pense que effectivement
c'est une porte de sortie indispensable
on a beaucoup évoqué le cadre
réglementaire et on sait combien il est
important au niveau européen il est
important à l'échelle nationale
aujourd'hui il y a quand même un maître
mot qui est celui de l'éducation aux
médias et à l'information ça existe à
s'en servir de ces médias sociaux donc
c'est quoi c'est à leur risque alors ils
savent s'en servir mieux que nous en
fait il faut pas faire
si pauvre que ça lorsqu'on regarde les
études très qui sont réalisées en détail
on s'aperçoit que finalement 39% des des
Français ne connaissent pas une des cas
de compétences de base dans le numérique
et c'est pas parce que finalement je
sais utiliser TikTok faire de la vidéo
que je sais envoyer mon cv donc il y a
il faut quand même affiner un peu le le
l'analyse mais je pense que justement on
pourrait répondre au mieux c'est la
formation des professeurs je pense qu'on
a une responsabilité tous à la fois une
responsabilité vous en tant
qu'évidemment journaliste en tant que
professeur mais également les pouvoirs
publics ont des responsabilités mais les
adultes les parents ont des
responsabilités et la question
d'éducation aux médias aujourd'hui elle
est centrale il y a un moyen très très
facile finalement aujourd'hui à
appliquer parce qu'on voit que les lois
s'accélèrent et un moyen très facile
aujourd'hui d'appliquer les choses c'est
d'aider justement l'école qui elle ne
peut pas tout et aider la formation des
professeurs des écoles par des
journalistes qui sont formés par des
professionnels de l'information
ce qui fabrique l'information et qui
savent comment ça fonctionne et ça on
peut le faire en mettant en fait dans
des conventions des chaînes de
télévision à la fois dans les contrats
d'objectifs et de moyens des chaînes
publics et évidemment dans les
conventions des plateformes aujourd'hui
avec des obligations la transposition de
la directive de service de médiovisuel
leur proposer de rendre un rapport tous
les trois mois pour savoir qu'est-ce
qu'il en était en matière d'éducation
médias à l'information et bien non ça il
faut absolument renforcer et ça ça peut
se faire très rapidement par les
législateurs en transformant la loi pour
vraiment l'industrialisation efficace de
cette éducation médias et à
l'information dans toutes les écoles
merci beaucoup à tous d'avoir participé
à ce débat je vais rappeler les titres
de vos livres Nathalie sonnaque le
nouveau monde des médias une urgence
démocratique chez Audi Jacob Olivier
lascar l'enquête sur Elon Musk l'homme
qui défilé la science c'est chez alizio
merci à tous encore une fois ici et en
duplex voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro
de sens public je vous dis à lundi et
vous pouvez retrouver évidemment tous
nos programmes sur notre plateforme
public senna.fr et on continuera de
parler de ces questions demain dans la
matinale puisque Oriane Mancini reçoit
Claude Malhuret justement le président
du groupe les indépendants au Sénat
belle soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]